everyone loves between two ferns but I
couldn't I actually felt like I had
entered a different reality when you had
President Obama between two ferns
because having watched that show for
many years and loved it actually Andy
and I got to be on it a bunch of years
ago to actually see that it got to that
point where you were sitting there doing
improv with the President of the United
States yeah at the White House yeah kind
of blew my mind I felt like we had
entered a new realm yeah
for better or ill yeah and it was a it
was hilarious
it was fantastic I had forgotten that I
interviewed the president yeah that was
the weird that was a weird thing that
went on because you know it's it's
you're interviewing the president United
States and yeah he it's it's a very
strange world and I went to the White
House before we shot it and there's a
little restaurant there in the White
House I think it's a Fridays no it's a
there's a restaurant like a cafeteria
that's like an ice cap but there's
waiters and and his staff were around I
was getting ready to go interview the
president and on the menu they brought
the dessert menu around there was a
thing on the menu called a chocolate
freedom so I saved that them not trying
to be funny you guys call the president
this right yeah
and they all said you have to ask him
that I'm like no I'm not gonna ask that
question but it was just weird that
chocolate freedom was on the menu and I
thought it was named after him right but
it has nothing to do I thought it was
you are I mean first of all he's really
funny and deadpan you're obviously
hilarious but the two of you worked
really well together in that one of the
things I couldn't believe is it's early
on you shush him he scripts the top and
you just go and I was like no one's ever
done no one's done that to him since
like probably 1988 children his children
do it yeah it is you were it took balls
I thought to be that I mean obviously
he's in on the joke but you were so
dismiss it was and he called me after it
was Louise shot between two ferns and
then there was a little bit of a few
days had gone by and he called me too I
guess to thank me and I was at a
construction site meet some ladies yeah
her smell and I was by myself at a
construction site and he
it's not better that way
no it's not no it's not but I was yeah
and unless you were driving by and had
to use the bathroom well there was a
good portage on yeah yeah sure but so he
calls me and then we chatted I don't
know if you guys have ever had a chance
to talk to the president one-on-one but
I get up I'm done with it
oh he says to me I hope this is good for
your career he says that to me and I
almost said to him I hope it improves
your career but I thought well the
comedy bits over so I'll be respectful
yeah so he we chatted the last thing he
said to me was okay I'll talk to you
later brother
and I I hung up my phone I have a flip
phone and I didn't know what to do
because I just talked to the President
of the United States that hasn't
happened to me since Taft so anyway I I
get up and I just take a picture of this
old chair Oh was in and there was a
traffic cone next to it at this at this
site and that I have a nice picture of
me of no not me just a chair to
commemorate my conversation with the
president chair at a construction site a
traffic cone next to it Wow framed in my
office that's Sophie it's Brandon your
office no it's not but it's going to be